carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
les doy la bienvenida desde el país
vascofrancés carrusel de las artes se
encuentra en el festival biarritz
américa latina' festival que celebra por
todo lo alto el cine y las culturas
latinoamericanas
[Música]
la ciudad de biarritz celebra tres
décadas de compromiso con el cine
latinoamericano como siempre con una
competencia en largometrajes cortos y
documentales 10 cintas aspiran al premio
el abrazo símbolo de la amistad entre
biarritz y américa latina'
el festival biarritz américa latina'
cumple 30 años convertido en una
manifestación cultural mayor para la
ciudad y una referencia para la difusión
del cine latinoamericano en francia- lo
escucharemos en la voz de quienes han
hecho este sueño posible
pero es el invitado de honor de esta
edición aniversaria una fiesta peruana
con despliegue de cine literatura y
sabores venidos del país andino
[Música]
en 1991 comenzó a escribirse una
historia de amistad entre biarritz y los
países latinoamericanos 30 años después
el festival biarritz américa latina se
ha convertido en una cita obligada para
los amantes del cine latinoamericano una
manifestación que ha sobrevivido al paso
del tiempo e incluso a la pandemia por
el coronavirus
[Música]
sí
en carrusel de las artes estamos muy
complacidos de volver al festival
biarritz américa latina y tenemos cita
ya mismo con el delegado general del
festival entonces viaja con tan
muchísimas gracias por recibirnos
nuevamente aquí en biarritz control al
gusto es un placer yo te agradezco
antoine son 30 años lo decíamos del
festival biarritz américa latina este
año 60 películas en todo el festival 30
de las cuales están en las secciones de
competencia a largometrajes cortos y
documentales diría usted que la
producción cinematográfica
latinoamericana sigue siendo dinámica y
pujante a pesar de la crisis que hemos
vivido y sentimos el año pasado los
efectos de la crisis pero este año hemos
visto 1500 películas para
construir esta edición y volvimos a un
nivel al nivel anterior a
2020 así que si se volvió la producción
con una producción independiente un poco
más dinámica que las producciones más
grandes pero vimos muchas muchísimas
cosas muy interesantes
el premio principal del festival es el
premio el abrazo al mejor largometraje
de ficción 10 películas este año en liza
por ese galardón películas que vienen de
argentina chile méxico brasil y por
primera vez dos películas dominicanas si
mira es lo que es genial cuando
organizas un festival de cine
latinoamericano es que siempre hay
países donde algo está pasando y creo
que es el caso de república dominicana
con dos películas muy distintas además
de directores jóvenes una película sobre
parejas y candela candela de andrés
farias que es un director que estuvo en
biarritz con su corto y que estamos
súper felices de invitar con su
largometraje y una película sobre
parejas también de natalia cabral y
oriol a estrada que son una pareja
justamente que hacen una un falso
documental cómico sobre ellos mismos
hacían una película nos encanta eso
descubrir nuevas películas de nuevos
países ya sé que es en el caso también
en el futuro
anthony en 2021 ustedes han escogido
este festival biarritz amérique a la
tiene una película argentina piedra
noche de iván funke es una cinta entre
drama y fantasía vamos a descubrir la ya
mismo
donde está
[Música]
el videojuego está mandando
lo rescataron del fondo del mar ocho
meses después y seguí andando se volvió
a prender
una pareja trata de recuperarse de la
dolorosa pérdida de su hijo único un año
atrás en la costa la visita de una amiga
coincide con el rumor de una extraña
criatura merodeando por la zona esa es
la historia de piedra noche del
argentino iván fundó una película
delicada sobre el duelo pero llena de
fantasía bueno la verdad que el conozco
el guión original de la película hace
muchos años y desde la primera vez que
lo leí era un drama muy triste pero
tenía un pequeño elemento fantástico que
me llamó mucho la atención y varios años
después cuando podemos comenzar la
producción de la película entendí que
era por ahí por ese elemento que había
que contar esta historia este drama de
estos personajes para que de alguna
manera envuelva
el drama de los personajes y era un poco
lo que hacía posible de que yo pueda
contar esta historia tan triste que
finalmente es la historia de la pérdida
de un hijo
[Música]
concretamos necesitas dormir
bien
menos mal que viniste
[Música]
necesito díaz esto conmigo
la película a través de esos elementos
fantásticos a través del tono en el que
yo quería articular la
no deja de ser luminosa que era lo que
me interesaba como todos sabemos lo
difícil que es levantarse el día a día y
todos transitamos nuestros dolores
entonces me parece que el cine no tiene
que necesariamente eso
y construir un mundo sino que por lo
menos construyó la posibilidad del mundo
y los personajes a raíz de la ausencia
de ese niño de alguna forma se ven
envueltos o caen adentro del imaginario
de ese niño y era un poco desde allí y
también es donde se cuenta la historia
dice
porque no creen
seguimos en carrusel de las artes aquí
en el festival de biarritz está en
compañía del delegado general del
festival entonces vi a antoine acabamos
de ver piedra noche una película que
tiene mucho de fantasía yo creo que ese
ha sido el hilo conductor de la
selección este año mucha fantasía en
esta selección sí es un poco un hilo
conductor que encontramos después de
haber seleccionado en las películas pero
hay muchas de las películas que
mostramos que hablan de mundos paralelos
creo que estamos en un periodo en el que
la humanidad se está desconectando con
el mundo y de sí mismo y justamente el
cine y el arte es una forma de crear de
imaginar una reconexión una nueva
conexión con sí mismo y con el mundo y
diría usted que quizás el cine
latinoamericano ha dejado un poco lo
social y lo político para adentrarse en
otro género que es ese fantástico la
fantasía sí creo que es algo que hemos
estado observando en los pasados años
creo que a los jóvenes cineastas
cineastas de latinoamérica
le siguen interesando temas sociales o
políticos pero ahora los tratan con
recursos cinematográficos distintos como
el género como lo fantástico y creo que
es algo que añade mucho más fuerza a las
políticas cuando el discurso político no
es frontal sino que pasa por el prisma
de una forma cinematográfica nueva nos
parece muy interesante bueno muchísimas
gracias antoine sería delegado general
del festival nosotros vamos a seguir en
la exploración de este festival biarritz
américa latina' lo decíamos son 30 años
de festival 30 años celebrando el cine y
las culturas latinoamericanas y es algo
que vamos a explorar ahora mismo con
melissa barra
tres décadas de cultura latinoamericana
que ya oye gran asiduo del festival de
biarritz resume en unas palabras yo
diría antes de todo que es una ventana
abierta sobre todos los países de
américa latina es una historia ya lejana
yaris es una ciudad muy bien situada por
estos intercambios y deseo que sigan y
que sigan mucho porque permite
verdaderamente conocer mejor a estos
países que lo merecen tantos
biarritz se acercó a países tan lejanos
porque históricamente el corazón latino
late fuerte en el país vasco y viceversa
como lo recuerda la alcaldesa de
biarritz maider aros takes hace 30 años
el alcalde de bogotá ha creado este
festival porque él tenía unos vínculos
particulares con américa latina pero yo
creo que tenemos una diáspora vasca en
américa latina' muy importante
y hemos vuelto a hacer lazos con esta
diáspora en américa latina y desde hace
más de 30 años es este vínculo que se ha
hecho natural
chile la alegría ya viene yo estoy
describiendo una realidad
donde está la violencia y esa relación
se ha afianzado durablemente y ahora
biarritz se ha convertido para muchos
cineastas latinoamericanos en una
vitrina como ninguna otra en el mundo se
han reforma presidencial festival el
festival de biarritz tiene muchísimo
reconocimiento entre los profesionales
todos quieren venir aquí el festival de
biarritz está muy bien ubicado es un
festival que tiene muchísimo
reconocimiento más que nada es el más
antiguo en europa tal vez en el mundo
que se dedica exclusivamente a las
culturas latinoamericanas es todo
sí no
creo que esto
en 2021 el festival de biarritz se viste
con los colores de perú el país invitado
de honor una celebración que incluye una
selección de 10 películas peruanas
recientes la literatura y las artes
gráficas del país andino son otro de los
platos fuertes de este año en biarritz y
alguien muy especial nos invitó a
descubrir el patrimonio gastronómico de
perú
[Música]
yo me llamo el burgués final siempre
cocina del restaurante el picaflor de
parís
restaurant peruano que funciona desde
hace 28 años y que soy nombrada
embajadora de la gastronomía peruana en
francia he venido a biarritz la locación
del festival de cinema latinoamericano
[Música]
bueno hemos elegido para esta semana un
abanico de especialidades que van
girando al torno del pescado con los
cebiches que hoy día es de mucho interés
y la papa con causa huancaína papa
rellena la quinoa mariscos una serie de
especialidades regionales
costeñas y de la sierra para poder
mostrar un poquito de nuestra riqueza
gastronómica peruana tenemos los ajíes
nuestro ají amarillo que es una de las
piezas importantes de la gastronomía
peruana es el limón limón verde que esto
es
nuestra
culantro el cilantro tul antro nuestra
canchita y este y mucho cariño para esta
cocina
el perú tiene es un jardín botánico de
frutos y legumbres con toda la
diversidad que tenemos en el perú y todo
el talento de estos jóvenes chefs que
hoy día han salido a la luz hemos hecho
una gastronomía extremamente rica y
refinada
mostrar una cultura gastronómica es a
dar a conocer una cultura de un pueblo a
través de lo que comemos sabemos quiénes
somos y pienso que a través de eso el
mundo nos descubre de otra manera y
estoy feliz que hoy día después de 28
años de carrera en el perú gastronómico
se le dé su lugar
[Música]
y con este festival de sabores vamos a
despedir nuestro programa especial
carrusel de las artes desde el festival
biarritz a américa latina y los dejamos
con el grupo santa machete que estuvo
presente en esta edición del festival
muchísimas gracias por su sintonía y
hasta la próxima
algunos pescadores van a bailar un rato
pues ellos llevan el ritmo como una vena
su parte no hay como unos pescadores van
a bailar la bamba después ellos ya van
el ritmo como navega a bailar
[Música]